Luke Skywalker has pretty much always
been at the center of the Star Wars
stories he was the hero whose journey
the entire original trilogy centered on
his birth was the end game of the
prequels and the new film series seems
to focus first on finding him and then
building his relationship with Rey but
in the footage for the last Jedi he
looks much more trouble than usual so
what does it mean that Luke's demeanor
seems so much darker than what we've
seen in the past let's explore some of
the possible consequences for Luke's new
outlook who's the last Jedi writer
director Rian Johnson said point blank
on Twitter that Luke is the last Jedi
mentioned in the title to episode 8 but
filmmakers lie to their audiences all
the time so until the movie hits
theaters it's fair game to speculate if
Luke has begun to journey down a path of
darkness he'd no longer be a Jedi and
the order would be done but perhaps what
Johnson meant is not that Luke is the
last Jedi ever but that he's the last of
the Jedi as we've come to know them
throughout the franchise the Jedi we've
seen so far in the Star Wars movies have
been plagued by politics and war and
have strayed from the Jedi code while
claiming to follow it their arrogance
and blindness led to their virtual
decimation and even Luke's path to
becoming a Jedi in the original trilogy
didn't seem to introduce a true New Jedi
Order so if my episode 8 Luke is turning
away from the teachings of the Jedi
himself then the Jedi as we come to know
them could be over leaving Luke as the
last Jedi of his kind the question is
this will the decline of that particular
type of Jedi happen while a new and
improved order is formed by say Rey it's
a nice idea at the very least is it even
a dark turn the teachings of the Jedi
Order adhere to a strict set of
philosophies that form a stark contrast
with those of the Sith the jedi believe
emotions dictating actions can lead to
the dark side meanwhile the Sith embrace
the full spectrum of emotion good and
bad and as we've seen characters like
ahsoka and the TV shows Clone Wars and
rebels have rejected the Jedi philosophy
without actually going to the dark side
the last Jedi heavily teases a darker
turn for Luke Skywalker but maybe he's
not actually going to the dark side he
could
certainly reject the Sitz teachings -
either way the rogue one debut of the
guardians of the Wills proves that the
force will still live on because it's
not always defined by Jedi Knights and
Sith Lords the force will find other
Guardians even if the Skywalker family
is finished the family name the
Skywalker saga has been a devastating
one Anakin became Darth Vader his
grandson Ben solo became kylo Ren and
now Luke has apparently failed at
passing the way of the Jedi on to the
next generation
for a family with not one but two
potential chosen ones meant to bring
balance to the force that seems like a
pretty lousy track record at some point
we've got to ask ourselves are the
Skywalker's doomed yes the force and
those who use it are always in a state
of flux in balance one minute and out of
it the next but the Skywalker's in
particular seem to have a more
tumultuous relationship with it and each
Skywalker actually seems to ultimately
doom the next Anakin may have saved Luke
but as time as Darth Vader is what
ultimately inspired Ben's solos turned
to darkness and Luke himself failed to
teach Ben the ways of the Jedi allowing
him to be seduced by Snoke and the dark
side if Luke is not in fact the chosen
one and he has turned away from the
light side the Skywalker family may not
receive another chance their story at
least as it relates to being guardians
of the force may well be over unless the
future of Rey Rey is a tremendously
powerful force user and certainly seems
to be on the side of good but she still
might not take up the traditional mantle
of the Jedi while being led to believe
that Rey will be a Jedi master student
it's becoming more clear that may not be
the case Lucas showed teaching Rey how
to Commander powers and how to become
more in touch with the force but that
isn't the same thing as a Jedi Master
training a Padawan learning to better
command the force won't automatically
make her a Jedi with Luke saving to
stray further away from the traditional
teachings of the Jedi Rey could be
exposed to elements of the darkside
during her training her journey through
the forest will be shaped by your
teacher and her teacher definitely seems
to be in a grim place that's not to say
ray will be evil or even that her
learning more about the dark side is a
bad thing
strictly adhering to a philosophy of
pure good and evil as
led to the fall of the Jedi to begin
with rather it seems likely rey is going
to be taught not to suppress and control
her emotions but to let them guide her
when the time is right and they might
even guide her to rescuing Luke himself
Luke from the moment he steps on screen
in the force awakens is clearly in need
of help with Rey's arrival he suddenly
faced the face of the pure-hearted young
force user who could restore his faith
ray thinks she's here to bring Luke back
to save the galaxy but the truth may be
that she's here to save him could she be
the key to restoring the Skywalker
legacy for good and the Jedi to thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]